In this lesson you're going
to learn how to add and
work with user interface
elements in iOS.
You're going to build the first part of
the Pitch Perfect app with the ability
to add buttons and connect those
buttons to code in your app.
We're going to be working with two
parts of the NVC diagram, the view and
the controller.
Our controller is called the view
controller and the view, for
now, is just called the view.
We won't see the code behind
a view classes just yet,
as we're going to be using the view
classes that Apple provides,
namely UIView, UILabel, and UIButton.
We call that the controller
part of the NVC parent,
is where we handle events from the view.
And we're going to be using
the view controller that Xcode has
already started for us,
the ViewController.swift class.
This is where the code, which will be
called by the buttons, will reside.
At the moment our view controller
is just named view controller.
But in a later lesson we'll name
it to something more meaningful
record view controller.
User interfaces are one of the key ways
your users will interact with your app.
Let's get started.